tell me why so stuck by screen juggies
to show the world that he is the literal
disaster artist go faster look at this
what's going on look at this oh my God
look at this cow right now dammit I
should drive this car you don't know how
to drive a [ __ ] the long voyage
yes that's it that's it yes yeah we go
I'm sorry I called you [ __ ] you're not
very nice person
ah your turn you fart right now go come
on we have to survive come on let's go
oh he got my foot on come on I cannot
stand this hey guys come on
hey guys this way with guitars rule die
right now
don't ringing involved watch what's
happening here come on guys
yeah
five four hey young people I'm your
president thank you for coming and
you've been selected to go to Mars
through outer space your courage is
inspiration for everyone in u.s. as well
global as you know well global country
yes sir but will you go to space because
we want to be someone else no dinosaurs
don't worry about dinosaurs does not
exist
maybe exist I don't even know but your
courage give us you society I know you
have great preparation thank you sir
good luck to you and while fuss is with
us and you are with us as well so good
luck have a nice trip
send us a postcard thank you
thanks to Tommy for coming and
celebrating the disaster artist DVD
launch with us make sure to check out
Tommy Wiseau film school on screen
junkies news and that's a good thing a
bad thing at the same time just do it